La victoria de Petro en Colombia, el gobierno
de Gabriel Boric en Chile, la posible vuelta
de Lula en Brasil o la llegada de Pedro Castillo
al poder en Perú.
Latinoamérica se encuentra inmersa, una vez
más, en una enorme ola de cambio político.
Un cambio que apuesta claramente por el resurgir
de los partidos y los políticos de izquierdas.
Una nueva izquierda, aparantemente mucho menos
radical y mucho más socialdemócrata que
aquella que conocimos con el llamado socialismo
del S.XXI.
Pero…
¿Y si os dijera que podemos encontrar una
pequeña excepción?
Un pequeño entre gigantes que está girando
al camino contrario y que aspira, incluso,
a convertirse en todo un modelo para el futuro
de la Argentina.
¿Sabéis a quien me refiero?
3, 2, 1….
Exacto, hablamos de Uruguay.
C1(“El éxito de un gobernante no se mide
en el reflejo de un espejo, se mide en el
reflejo de cada uno de los uruguayos y la
gente que vive en el país.
Si la gente se mira al espejo cuando termine
nuestro gobierno y es más libre, el gobierno
es exitoso, si no lo es, habremos fracasado,
para mí en lo fundamental.
Luis Lacalle Pou, Presidente de Uruguay)
La historia que veremos hoy comenzó el domingo
27 de octubre del 2019.
Ese día, tal y como ocurre cada cinco años,
tuvieron lugar las elecciones presidenciales
en Uruguay.
Y no hablamos de unas elecciones cualquiera.
Por primera vez en 15 años se produjo una
alternancia en el poder.
Ese día el Frente Amplio, la coalición de
izquierdas que llevaba gobernando Uruguay
desde el año 2004 fue derrotada.
Una derrota que para ser justos hay que decir
que se produjo por un estrecho, estrechísimo
margen.
Fijaos.
(Tras quedar segundo a mucha distancia del
Frente Amplio en primera vuelta y con la memoria
de las derrotas en segunda vuelta de su padre
en el 2009 y de él mismo en el 2014, Lacalle
Pou, finalmente se hizo con el poder por un
estrechísimo margen de poco más de punto
y medio.
Apenas 37.000 votos bastaron para cambiar
por completo la política de Uruguay.)
Ahora bien, ¿Qué hizo que los votantes uruguayos
decidieran apostar por Lacalle Pou?
¿Por qué se produjo este cambio de 180 grados?
¿Qué supone en el contexto político latinoamericano?
Y la pregunta más importante de todas: Ha
pasado ya tiempo más que suficiente desde
la elección, así que la cuestión que tenemos
que hacernos es: ¿Cómo ha cambiado Uruguay
desde entonces?
Pues bien, veamoslo.
T1(EL NUEVO MANDATO POPULAR)
¿Qué hizo que Lacalle Pou lllegara al poder
tras 15 años de dominio político del Frente
Amplio?
¿Con qué país se encontró exactamente
el actual presidente de Uruguay?
Queridos amigos, amigas, para responder a
esta pregunta tenemos que desplazarnos hasta
el año 2019.
En ese tiempo podemos destacar 3 grandes temas
que preocupaban e, incluso, amenazaban el
futuro del país.
En primer lugar tenemos la cuestión de la
seguridad.
Y es que, veréis, Uruguay ha sido siempre
un país relativamente seguro, sin embargo
eso comenzó a cambiar a partir del año 2011.
En los siguientes 8 años la tasa de homicidios
practicamente se duplicó, y lo que nunca
había sido una preocupación relevante, la
seguridad, comenzó a situarse como uno de
los temas clave de la agenda política.
La situación estaba empeorando tanto que,
incluso, algunos sectores empezaron a pedir
que las fuerzas armadas tomaran el control
de la seguridad interna en detrimento de la
propia policia.
N1(3 de febrero de 2019: La inseguridad, el
tema que más preocupa a Uruguay de cara a
las elecciones.
InfoBae)
N2(25 de marzo de 2019: Preocupación por
el aumento récord de asesinatos y robos violentos
en Uruguay.
Los homicidios crecieron un 45,8% y los robos
violentos un 53,5% en el último año.
Infobae)
Pero eso no era todo.
En segundo lugar, tras 15 años de políticas
redistribuitvas del Frente Amplio, la economía
estaba agotada, practicamente caput.
(El crecimiento económico de Uruguay pasó
del 4,6% en 2013 al crecimiento nulo en 2019;
la pobreza había comenzado a crecer y el
déficit público se había disparado hasta
prácticamente el 5% del PIB.
Uno de los mayores descuadres presupuestarios
en toda la historia de Uruguay.
Para colmo, las crecientes regulaciones y
la cada vez mayor intervención del gobierno
hicieron que el país cayera hasta el puesto
101 en el ranking Doing Business del Banco
Mundial.)
En otras palabras, que el miedo a que la “enfermedad
argentina” hiciera mella en el país era
algo más que real.
Y por último tenemos una de las epidemias
más comunes en todos los países hispanos:
la corrupción.
Para que os hagais una idea el propio vicepresidente
del país, Raúl Sendic fue acusado de corrupción.
Unas acusaciones por las que terminó siendo
condenado en 2021.
Inseguridad, estancamiento económico y corrupción:
tres ingredientes que juntos signnifican una
cosa: degradación institucional.
Sí, en 2019 Uruguay era uno de los mejores
países de Latinoamérica en términos económicos,
políticos y sociales.
Pero las cosas simple y llanamente no estaban
marchando por el buen camino.
Y justo ahí apareció Lacalle Pou con un
mensaje muy claro: dar un giro de 180 grados
a las políticas del país.
Y, amigos, amigas, eso fue ni más ni menos
lo que le permitió derrotar al Frente Amplio.
La promesa de construir un nuevo Uruguay.
Claro que, amigos, una cosa es ganar las elecciones
y otra muy distinta tener un cheque blanco.
La escasa diferencia con la que ganó las
elecciones le ha obligado al gobierno a depender
de una compleha alianza de 5 partidos para
poder alcanzar la mayoría tanto en el Congreso,
tanto en la Cámara de Representantes como
en el Senado.
Es la conocida como “Coalición Multicolor”,
claro que ya os podéis imaginar que más
allá del nombre mantener a 5 partidos unidos
no siempre es una tarea facil.
Y desde luego es algo que te obliga a tener
a todos contentos.
En otras palabras, que para pactar cualquier
reforma hace falta muuucho diálogo y mucha
negociación.
Para colmo, llegar al poder en 2019 y sufrir
una pandemia en 2020…
Es todo, ¿Cómo decirlo?
Toda una puñeta.
Llegas al poder y al poco tiempo tus prioridades
políticas y económicas cambian por completo.
Con todo, el gobierno de Lacalle Pou ha conseguido
introducir importantes cambios en el país.
Cambios radicalmente distintos a lo que se
viene haciendo en practicamente todos los
países de la región y que en algunos casos
pueden terminar provocando un enorme choque
político con sus países vecinos.
¿Quieres saber de qué estamos hablando y
cómo está cambiando el país charrua?
Pues…
Atentos.
T2(RECONSTRUIR URUGUAY)
Prestad mucha atención a la siguiente noticia:
N3(“Uruguay, Bahamas y Portugal: los países
elegidos por los argentinos por sus beneficios
impositivos.
Infobae)
Evidentemente Uruguay no es ni mucho menos
un paraíso fiscal, pero sí que tiene condiciones
mucho mejores que la Argentina, sobre todo
si las rentas proceden del exterior.
Y sobre todo lo que ha mejorado son las perspectivas
de futuro, lo cuál resulta particularmente
importante cuándo quieres poner tus ahorros
a buen resguardo ¿No te parece?.
Y desde luego, cosas como estas ayudan y mucho:
N4(8 de septiembre del 2020: Uruguay aprobó
las “vacaciones fiscales” por 10 años
para los extranjeros que obtengan la residencia.
InfoBae)
N5(7 de octubre del 2020: Más beneficios
en Uruguay: Lacalle Pou aprobó una flexibilización
impositiva para empresas que se radiquen e
inviertan en ese país.
InfoBae)
Ahora bien de todas los procesos de reforma
que el gobierno uruguayo ha puesto en marcha
durante los últimos años hay uno que destaca
por encima del resto:
Me estoy refiriendo, por supuesto, a la conocida
como Ley de Urgente Consideración, LUC para
los amigos.
Hablamos de una larguísima ley que con 476
artículos ha metido mano en todo tipo de
temas: desde la economía hasta la educación
pasando por los servicios de comunicaciones.
Es el gran proyecto de transformación del
gobierno.
Y ojo porque tras su aprobación un recurso
del Frente Amplio hizo que gran parte de los
cambios tuvieran que ser sometidos a referéndum…
Y de nuevo los uruguayos y de nuevo por un
estrecho margen de apenas 2 puntos, votaron
a favor de las reformas.
N6(El Ejecutivo uruguayo sale reforzado tras
un referéndum que mantiene al país dividido.
EFE)
N7(Uruguay: con estrecho margen, el Gobierno
gana referendo clave para su gestión.
Por solo 22.000 votos de diferencia, la mayoría
de los uruguayos respaldó la opción para
no derogar 135 de 476 artículos de la denominada
Ley de Urgente Consideración (LUC), impulsada
por el presidente Luis Lacalle Pou.
France 24h)
Ahora bien, ¿qué es lo que dice exactamente
esta LUC?
¿Cuáles son sus cambios más destacados?
Pues entre las principales reformas podemos
encontrar:
En materia económica se ha fijado un límite
máximo al crecimiento del gasto público
y un límite al nivel de deuda, así como
la creación de un Consejo Fiscal para evaluar
los diferentes proyectos de gasto público
e intentar evitar derrochos políticos.
En matería de trabajo, a partide ahora cuándo
se produzca una jornada de huelga, se reconocerá
expresamente el derecho de los empresarios
y empleados a trabajar si así lo desean.
Y es que hasta ahora aunque un trabajador
no quisiera adherise a una huelga, la conocida
como libertad sindical pasiva del 2006, podía
impedirle trabajar ese día.
En la misma línea la LUC también declara
ilegítimos e ilegales los piquetes que impidan
la libre circulación de personas, bienes
o servicios, tanto en espacios públicos como
privados.
Es decir, que puedes ponerte en huelga pero
no puedes obligar a otros a que la secunden
ni tampoco puedes para el país.
(Luego en términos de seguridad, la ley amplía
las circunstancias y los lugares en los que
tanto cíviles como polícias pueden recurrir
a la legítima defensa y en términos de vivienda
se introduce un nuevo régimen de alquiler
voluntario que reduce los derechos de los
inquilinos.
Este réfimen reconoce, por ejemplo, los desalojos
más rápidos en caso de impagos.
La idea es que más propietarios saquen sus
inmuebles al mercado y esto haga bajar los
precios.)
Bien, estos son solo algunos de los muchos
cambios con los que el gobierno de Lacalle
Pou quiere dar un golpe de timón al rumbo
de Uruguay.
Ahora el siguiente paso parece ser la peliaguda
reforma de la seguridad social después de
que en 2020 una comisión de expertos confirmará
lo que un secreto a voces:
Con el enevejecimiento de la población el
sistema público de la seguridad social tal
y como está montado en Uruguay es inviable.
Para que os hagais una idea el gasto en seguridad
social del país charrua es similar al de
España y más elevado que el de países tan
ricos como Dinamarca o Noruega.
Así que toca ponerse manos a la obra.
En fin, con todo esto que hemos visto, ¿qué
queréis que os diga?
Te podrán gustar más o menos, pero amigos,
creo que una cosa está clara: no se parecen
nada a lo que está ocurriendo en el resto
de América Latina.
Pero esperad un momento, que no hemos terminado.
Otra apuesta clave, fundamental y completamente
disruptiva de este gobierno tiene mucho que
ver con la política exterior y sobre todo
con Mercosur.
Hablamos de una apuesta que puede terminar
ni más ni menos que haciendo que Montevideo
mande a la porra a Buenos Aires y a Brasilia.
¡Atentos!
T3(UN NUEVO CAMINO AL MUNDO))
Fijaos en toda esta declaración de intenciones:
C2(“El deber mío como uruguayo es decir
ábranme el mundo que si nos abren el mundo
vamos a andar bien seguro".
Luis Lacalle Pou, Presidente de Uruguay)
Amigos, amigas, desde su llegada al poder
Lacalle Pou entendió que sobre todo hay algo
que no funciona en esta región del mundo.
Algo de lo que os hemos hablado muchas veces
en VisualPolitik:
La política de sustitución de importaciones
y el proteccionismo galopante que caracteriza
a estos países.
Así que, dicho y hecho, para disgusto de
la Argentina, - luego entenderéis porque
- nada más llegar al poder al nuevo gobierno
de Uruguay se le metio entre ceja y ceja lidar
con tres importantes caballos de batalla en
su política exterior:
Primero, hacer que esta sea más pro-mercado.
Segundo, que contribuya a flexibilizar Mercosur.
Y tercero que facilite la llegada al país
de más inversión extranjera directa..
Bueno, eso y también poner tierra de por
medio con todas las satrapías populistas
de la región.
Es decir, condenar claramente a los regímenes
de Cuba, Nicaragua y Venezuela.
Pero no nos desviemos.
Centrémonos en lo que está siendo la gran
apuesta en materia exterior del gobierno uruguayo.
Fijaos:
C3(“Uruguay necesita abrirse al mundo [..] Si
nos acompañan, bien; si no, vamos solos"
Luis Lacalle Pou, Presidente de Uruguay)
C4(Sobre Mercosur: “Estamos en el barco,
hay que pensar quién es la carga.
Queremos seguir adelante y lo vamos a hacer.
[En Uruguay] Estamos tratando de negociar
con China, Turquía, con el Reino Unido" Luis
Lacalle Pou, Presidente de uruguay)
Más claro, agua.
El actual gobierno uruguayo tiene claro que
para lograr más inversiones y más crecimiento
económico el país tiene que abrirse al mundo.
El problema es que al mismo tiempo que quiere
negociar nuevos acuerdos comerciales, Uruguay
pertecene a Mercosur y eso limita mucho su
margen de maniobra.
Qué es lo que explica noticias como esta:
N8(La rebeldía de Uruguay tensa al máximo
Mercosur.
El País)
Os lo hemos contado también en VisualPolitik,
el Mercado Común del Sur, Mercorus no funciona,
no al menos como debería.
Se supone que esta institución tenía el
objetivo de promover el comercio en América
del Sur, sin embargo con un arancel externo
común que más que duplica el promedio mundial
y ciertas limitaciones a la hora de negociar
con terceros países, en la práctica este
acuerdo funciona más bien como una barrera
proteccionista.
Y por eso, el gobierno de Lacalle Pou se ha
lanzado a toda una guerra política para que
el bloque sea más flexible, se reduzca ese
arancel externo común y los países miembros
puedan negociar acuerdos comerciales con terceros
países por su cuenta.
Algo que la regulación actual de Mercosur
impide.
Claro que hasta el momento los resultados
no han sido nada positivos.
Buenos Aires sobre todo sigue empecinado en
que este bloque sea lo que es hoy en día:
una especie de caja cerrada que en lugar de
alentar el comercio lo frene.
[Bueno, ya sabéis la alergia que los políticos
argentinos le tienen al libre comercio y la
globalización.]
La falta de interés real en sacar adelante
el acuerdo de libre comercio con la Unión
Europea es una buena prueba de ello.
Ahora bien, aquí, la cuestión es que Uruguay
se encuentra cerca de firmar un acuerdo de
libre comercio con China y probablemente también
con otros países…
Y tan solo China pesa ya más en la cesta
de exportaciones de Uruguay que sus vecinos
de Mercosur.
¿Quiere decir esto que el país “charrua”
podría terminar abandonando Mercosur?
No parece algo fácil porque todavía sus
socios de bloque dominan las importaciones…
Pero si las cosas siguen así en el futuro
no sería algo descartable.
El mundo es mucho más grande que Mercosur.
De hecho desde el 2019 el peso de las exportaciones
en el PIB que venía cayendo desde el 2014
ha comenzado a crecer de nuevo, y en 2021
aunque el saldo exterior siguió siendo negativo,
tuvo su segundo menor nivel de los últimos
12 años.
Solo fue mejorado por el dato extraordinario
del 2020 cuando las importaciones colapsaron
por la pandemia.
¿Y qué significa esto?
Pues, que no se trata solo de un simple empecinamiento
del presidente.
El mercado exterior le está viniendo muy
pero que muy a Uruguay.
Y de hecho las exportaciones se dispararon
en 2021 y están haciendo lo propio en 2022.
Ahora la crisis alimentaria mundial provocada
por la invasión rusa de Ucrania promete impulsar
aún más las exportaciones.
Y de llevarse a cabo los planes de Lacalle
Pou está claro que el sector exterior jugaría
un papel clave en el futuro económico de
Uruguay.
Así que como veis
En definitiva, a pesar de la pandemia, la
economía ha mejorado, el desempleo está
a punto de batir su mejor registro en 7 años,
la pobreza se está contrayendo y los delitos
se han reducido sustancialmente.
Queda mucho por hacer, pero los datos son
claros, hoy por hoy las cosas en Uruguay parece
que marchan por buen camino, al menos por
un camino mejor que el que transitaban en
2019.
Y eso en una región atestada de problemas
es todo un soplo de aíre fresco.
Esto es quizás lo que explica que Uruguay
esté siendo prácticamente la única excepción
al giro a la izquierda que se está experimentando
en toda América Latina.
La pregunta ahora es, ¿pueden las reformas
impulsadas por Lacalle Pou convertirse en
un modelo para países como la Argentina?
¿Hasta dónde llegarán los cambios impulsados
por el actual presidente de Uruguay?
¿Revalidarán los uruguayos esta senda de
reformas en las elecciones de 2024?
Estas son las preguntas y en este caso vuestras
son las respuestas.
Si os parece, dejadnos vuestras impresiones
en los comentarios y abramos debate.
Y cómo siempre si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros
a VisualPolitik.
Una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.
---